hello reject nation it's greg alba here
i have a new friend in the reject family
to Caitlyn
nicole foster home is a lame case on the
Cole Foster who has the channel big
screen books I've actually seen her
channel for quite a while now and she
lives in California but like two hours
away so we've never collab she's down
here today she's gonna go to attend a
special movie premiere she hits me up
saying she's coming down yeah you gotta
come on the channel that'd be great yeah
and on her channel she does a lot of
trailer reactions and such but one of
her biggest things is covering a lot of
book topics movies related to books or
comic books and I asked her beforehand
if she's read ready player one which you
have yeah am I correct long time ago I'm
playing on rereading we're gonna reread
it how do you book one book what I think
you take me and I love to read a graphic
novel averagely 12 to 15 books a month
whoa
on top of school and three jobs and yeah
YouTube channel and volleyball yes well
I
Cobra SXSW they did a screening of ready
player one which supposedly Spielberg
was nervous to screen for some reason
there's some pretty positive early
reactions out and I loved hearing these
early reactions so I thought I'd go
through this with you to see what's
going on Alicia Malone who I've seen on
many movie channels don't you read that
one for us ready player one the SXSW
crowd ate it up whoo okay that's pretty
good but pop-culture references are a
lot of fun geeky Glee to see everything
together on the big screen I just wanted
more of the real world a more character
backstory definitely recommend reading
the book first interesting so definitely
the book like has a lot of the
characters backstory that must have been
just something that they weren't able to
translate time constraint and I like a
two-hour format exactly you see that's
been my concern that I've been
expressing on the Internet when you got
a big book like this which I've never
read but I know the big problem I can
have
these books is you try to just throw in
the entertaining scene it's a lot but I
know what makes a book like that so
intriguing is the characters is the
world-building I mean this is just the
one feedback we've heard so far but this
is surprise yeah it's not surprising
this is the matter why not what I
expected people to say about ready
player one yeah that sounds about into
what I was expecting and it seems like
what people are most excited about or
the pop-culture 80s references it's
great but it is nice the book where you
really get to like you really get to see
the character you feel the world think
you're much more involved and definitely
with book to movie adaptations that's
often lacking what I thought we got a
morning you got more to check out here
Eric vespi you know I'll read the guys
and you read the girls so we have a
quality Spielberg just said he makes
many films like the post from behind the
camera
he made ready player one from the
audience that's the perfect summation of
this experience hmm that was that even
mean yeah maybe you made it more for
audience enjoyment
yeah just to make a popcorn yeah lick
see I'm wondering how fans of the book
will honestly respond to that yeah
because I know that the movie was
covered in bile author of the book which
it sounded like more I had more faith in
it after I heard that's me too but this
seems to just be along the lines of yeah
just fun popcorn entertainment right now
I imagine like for someone like you
who's read the book that's a little bit
lackluster yeah reading the book like
I'm just like super invested you know
little details yeah yeah it sounds like
from this one ready player one from the
audience made it more for the enjoyment
of the audience which if it's still
enjoyable movie I'm sure will be fun
then exactly like if it's still fun and
entertaining it's still appreciated oh
but he also said so yeah I love
I like you move I like you see I grew up
on a lot of the movies that it's being
referenced that I see in the trailers
and such I'm excited to see that stuff
it seems like the cool thing about it
that skepticism I had was is it really
gonna be featured in the movie you know
or they just showing you the moments
that are in the movie making it seem
like it's but just from these couple of
quick feedback it sounds like they're
really honing and all that kind of
nostalgia which I'm sure is a positive
thing forward where people have read the
book but I've just seen the trailers are
really excited yeah because that's what
they're gonna want to see totally read
all of Emily Yoshida's the biggest
surprise we'll start here well everyone
relax ready player one will indeed be
the biggest thing in the world that is
quite a statement okay and then she goes
the biggest surprise for me is how good
these wacky avatars look and feel it's
maybe the most successful part of the
film and I am shocked to report this
okay everything else I mean ym MV you
know who you are
even I begrudgingly had to clap for one
hashtag reference elate the best
possible premiere setting for this thing
this seems to be exactly what I thought
the game would be which is just honing
in on the nostalgia and honing in on the
pop-culture references and the geeky
side of people so that's probably what
senior director Steven up with all them
Millennials and whatnot
Frank Cullotta says ready player one is
nerdy as hell but it's hard not to leave
the theater with a huge smile smile on
your face pure Spielberg Ian joy
absolutely I like pure because if
there's one thing I want from the
Spielberg in category is more than
spectacle because Philbert one thing
that he used to be is consistently
amazing and is this sense of wonder and
awe it sounds like this movie's a lot of
fun but I haven't quite picked up on
people responding in the sense of wonder
and joy to be had from it but hey if
people are walking out with a good time
Eric on ready player one feels like
Spielberg watch a ton of Luke bass on
movies and decided to out to be nice in
terms of pure spectacle it's the most
astonishing thing he's ever done
never underestimate Steve it's cool he
can still do big spectacle because his
last big spectacles like what aventures
a Tintin or I didn't see that what is
the big the big the big thing the big
movie from Johanna Robinson generally
still shifting through my ready player
one feelings but it's telling that some
fanboys I've already yelled at me for
not coming out of the gate singing its
praises that's exactly the culture way
rp1 attempts to grapple with what's rp1
ready player one right right shame on
you for not having the same opinion as
all the fanboys all the fanboys want you
to have punch oh this cacophonous
eyesore ready player one pause it's a
corporate bigwig who is exploits fan
culture for profit as its villain the
irony of that is giving me a headache
there is no love letter to pop culture
it's a crass played a nostalgia it
offers nothing new or exciting we just
got two opinions in a row that were like
it sounds like it's a little bit
manipulative in a way using yeah like
let's just throw this [ __ ] in there
instead of honing in on the characters
in the backstory in the world well we
almost jinxed each other yeah
[Music]
that's kind of how I've been feeling
this is more along the lines of what
I've been concerned about yeah I feel
like I'm gonna feel a hybrid of both of
what we've heard I feel like I'm gonna
feel a hybrid of entertaining but you
know a little bit kind of manipulative
and what its kind of doing yeah okay I
see this yeah the uniqueness I'm
genuinely angry that Spielberg is so
careless with this own legacy slapping
it references to Jurassic Park with all
care of a monkey slinging feces
she's variation she does not like crazy
Oh Robert Rodriguez though here we go
ready player one is classic Spielberg
fun what a blast can't wait to see it
again
rewards repeat viewings tons of great
references visual and hearts so kick ass
it blew the speaker's ready player one
seems like the exact kind of movie
Robert Rodriguez would wanna watch
that's not entirely surprising I mean
there's a lot of these here we're not
gonna read all of them guys Halim at
donato after ready player one glitch
twice for some problems the battle is
over it's exactly what you'd expect if
you're excited you'll love it if you're
dreading it yeah not for you I mean I
got striped Chucky Freddy and Jason all
in the same movie that's cool I knew
Freddy was it in in Chucky plus fans of
The Shining you'll be treated to an
entire set piece horror fans is kind of
a ridiculous collection of cross
franchise ridiculousness
it sounds like this could be a mess I
guess we just got to go in and yeah cuz
even looking at uh there's a quick
glance of these other ones right here
like yeah great
like Joe Vargas from angry Joe what a
fantastic love letter to games in pop
culture from mr. Spielberg an awesome
book is now an awesome film every gamer
should see ready player one super fun
extremely satisfying offers a ton of new
things even for book readers AJ's badass
Seal of Approval angry Joe show he tends
to not like a lot of things I've seen a
lot of his reviews so the fact that he's
giving this movie high praise he is a
gamer and he's read the book this might
actually be the most accurate this might
be the best one to actually saw for a
gamer because it's like if Spielberg
saying he made it for the audience or
from the audience from the audience to
be the book and the gamer inside of us
and the people who love these 80s
references and whatnot for dude who's
like familiar with like all those
territories it sounds like this
computers like these that audience
member yeah while I have my skepticisms
and while the reactions to here are like
really diverse like huge a mixture of
responses here and that actually makes
me even more curious to see if it was
all positive I'd be like yeah I gotta
check it out but I get more intrigued by
movie what I'm like how am I gonna yeah
we're honestly like a 50/50 percentage
can make me go hmm I want to go is find
out for myself that's why okay I get
really curious to see to see which which
part I'm making sweet Kailyn thanks for
being here thank you for having me well
shoot a couple more Thanks yeah guys are
you excited for ready player one have
any of these reactions swayed you or
lowered your expectations or heighted
your expectations put it in the comment
boxes below you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our vids is up because subscribe buttons
do nothing you can check us out on
patreon full-length Q&A videos we do
weekly video responses full-length TV
show reactions and music video reactions
over there a bunch of other stuff as
well but most importantly what you must
do is subscribe to big screen books
Caitlyn Nicole
over here she has a wonderful wonderful
YouTube channel she clearly knows her
stuff can clearly give commentary you
know and that's like an important thing
to have especially in the female
atmosphere of that is YouTube so so
happy to have you here link in
description box for her channel link in
the top pink comment as well see you
guys soon
[Music]